hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week
because Comic Con is coming up I wanted
to do a preview of all the things that
game of thrones is going to be doing
there including all the merch that you
can blow all your savings on as well as
the panels and all the separate stuff
that george r martin is doing it is a
pure exercise in masochism so if you
can't go don't worry you'll live longer
I will be uploading that Hall H panel
and I'm gonna be doing a special
giveaway in addition to my weekly book
giveaway so I'll explain that all at the
end of this video be sure to subscribe
to get everything it's going to be crazy
but it's going to be a lot of fun
starting with the big stuff first comic
con starts this wednesday july twenty
third and ends on sunday the 27th the
biggest stuff always happens on friday
and saturdays the big hall h panel is
friday the twenty-fifth at 140 p.m.
pacific time i'll be recording a whole
bunch of panels but because you guys
have all voted in my straw poll Game of
Thrones is by far the winner so that's
going to be the first panel that I
upload on Friday you can actually keep
voting on that straw poll i'll leave the
link open throughout the week because
internet at comic-con is terrible I've
made some upgrades to my emergency
preparedness kit so I should be able to
upload the panel by 8 p.m. pacific time
but i'll keep you guys posted on social
so links for all that stuff at the
bottom of the description if I have to
I'll break it into two separate videos
or just cut out all the parts with
people screaming over people talking
just to make it shorter season five is
filming right now so HBO is only flying
in a couple of the cast members there's
Gwendoline Christie who also just
started work on Star Wars Episode seven
Nikolaj coster-waldau Natalie Dormer kit
harington all the women in Hollywood
probably right if they didn't make him
come then there's Rose Leslie obviously
we have to have a John and Egret final
reunion rory mccann and Maisie Williams
team-fucked the king sophie Turner and
Pedro Pascal who I think is going to end
up being the fan favorite dan and dave
are gonna be there too george RR martin
of course who also does a bunch of stuff
on his own Craig Ferguson is gonna be
moderating so brace myself jokes are
coming he's actually a really good panel
moderator so I'm really happy they
picked him Peter Dinklage and Lena
Headey are the most notable absences but
they're busy filming other movies right
now so it is a bit of a bummer so next
big question what are they going to do
on that panel Game of Thrones panels are
a little bit different for most of the
big hall h movie and TV panels they
usually do not show off new tray
they do talk a lot about next season
though mostly it's QA where the cast
tells stories about all the awesome
stuff they do on set in the way they
perceive their characters like a lot of
their personal feelings about what
happened on the show that season or
what's happening next season with our
character the biggest questions you'll
probably see them get a start you know
Johnny great stuff re and the Hound
stuff and Dan and Dave and Martin
questions will mostly be about the show
passing the books Dan and Dave get asked
those questions all the time and they're
really nice about answering but george
RR martin has given them like a
blueprint about where all the characters
need to end by the last season so even
if the show passes the books which it
will they'll be fine nightmare scenario
we get the season eight before winds of
winter it could totally happen so
prepare yourself if that actually ends
up happening it looked more like what
walking dead is on TV it just vastly
diverged from the source material and
all but the most important places so
like i said i'll post at least the best
parts of the panel this friday night
just depending on how good the internet
is last year jason momoa crashed it so
with any luck the new mountain Hathor
bjornsen will crash it and we can get a
Pedro Pascal rematch in fact let me know
if you agree but I feel like HBO would
be better served just renting out like a
fighting rink and just having them
reenact the fight instead of doing a
traditional panel I just feel like that
would be more entertaining but next on
the agenda what about the other game of
throne stuff that's happening at
comic-con there's always george RR
martin events separate from the TV show
like just for book stuff and then
there's all the new merch that you can
blow your savings on so this probably
won't blow your mind but george RR
martin has a new comic book that has
absolutely nothing to do with song of
ice and fire that he's going to be
promoting he'll be doing a full panel
for it it's called in the house of the
worm and it feels like a very john
carter e of march type story where it's
on another planet but it is a fantasy
story he's very nice about answering
winds of winter questions whenever he
goes around and does other non song of
ice and fire stuff so if he says
anything in that panel that is like new
information I'll included my next bonus
video but I'm not going to be recording
that panel here's the info and all the
new swag they're going to be selling a
lot of this stuff you will be able to
find online later like on Amazon in case
you're not going to be there there are a
lot of exclusive things that happen at
comic-con but most of the game of
thrones merch that's going to be there
isn't going to be exclusive to comic-con
so HBO is gonna have a big pop up shop
in the gaslamp district selling a bunch
of stuff that's away from the convention
center so you
need a badge to get in that's going to
be open thursday through sunday then
Funko pop is going to be on the
convention floor selling their regular
figures and a new line called mystery
minis that are black and white versions
of the dead characters so you can
totally buy a black and white Ned Stark
mini they've also got a new fuzzy
version of ghosts and a glowing white
Walker head Dark Horse Comics has a
couple things they'll be selling a
flayed man Bolton map marker which is
kind of terrifying a Lannister shield
and minis of all the dragons 30 the
company that makes those really awesome
dead space statues will be selling their
first game of thrones one it's gonna be
Tyrion you'll be able to buy that online
eventually too and then David Peterson
the person who creates all the languages
for the show like Dothraki and valerian
he has a new book that they're going to
be promoting they're called living
language Dothraki he's gonna have his
own booth will they'll be running games
all weekend where you come in like
little swag prizes that's all the
official HBO and big publisher stuff
that's happening but artists alley is
always a good place to hit up if you
have a badass idea for a sketch of
Tyrion writing drogon and you want to
commission someone to yank it out of
your brain I actually do have a few
artist friends so whenever season 5 gets
here next year I might do some giveaways
based on stuff like that speaking of
which here's the details on my comic con
give away i'm giving away a ghost in a
drogue on funko pop figure to two
different people each person just gets
one of them all you have to do to
participate is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video so the week
after Comic Con I'll just pick two
random people from the comments on this
video so it's gonna be open a little bit
longer than normal giveaways this is all
in addition to the regular book giveaway
I'm still doing that this week too which
reminds me congratulations to Michael
Pletka you're this week's winner I'll
reach out to you on your channel for
details so big reminders let me just
make sure I'm not forgetting anything
Friday night this week posting big game
of thrones panel I'm posting a bunch of
other panels too but that's just the
really big one also be tweeting the
out of the panel while it's happening so
you can follow me on social if you want
those links for that at the bottom of
the description and looks like that's
pretty much it for now so in the
meantime click here to learn all about
the golden company and click here to
learn all about the Blackfyre rebellion
thank you so much watching I'll see you
guys tonight high fives
you